Let's compare firewalls with IDS.
A network IDS performs
passive monitoring.
That is, while the IDS is copying and
analyzing the network traffic,
the traffic is continuing
to reach its destination.
Traffic analysis can take
a lot of computing power, and
therefore the IDS can be overloaded
by large body morph traffic.
When an IDS is overloaded, it cannot
detect intrusion in a timely manner.
That is, it fails to
adequately protect a network.
We call this situation fail open,
meaning that when the IDS fails,
the network is open to intrusions.
On the other hand,
a firewall performs active filtering.
That is, all traffic must
pass through the firewall and
the firewall performs relatively
simpler and more efficient analysis.
However, it can still be overloaded
by large volume of traffic.
When this happens, it will simply
not let the traffic go through.
We call this fail close,
meaning that when a firewall fails,
the internal network is closed to
the external network, and it is safe.